Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Stand back, Sharks.
Gluten, allergens, calories?
Never!
You have to be ready
for the unexpected.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my God.
We have a chance to help
mold babies' immune systems.
This is good stuff.
There's nothing else like it.
‐♪ It's pure genius ♪
‐[ Laughs ]
My two cents on this thing?
We don't want
your advice.
I hate when you play
big shot.
[ Laughs ]
When you say you have a Shark
and it's Mr. Wonderful,
there's Sharks, and then
there's [Vocalizes]
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a genius idea
in the beverage space.
♪♪
Whoo!
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Alex Bayer.
I'm the founder and CEO
of Genius Juice.
We are seeking $250,000
in exchange for 7% equity.
Instead of talking
about our product,
we're gonna sing about it.
And here we go.
[ Upbeat soft rock music plays ]
[ Snapping fingers ]
♪ Coconut ♪
♪ Coconut smoothie ♪
♪ Whole coconut blended up ♪
♪ So creamy ♪
♪ Whole coconut in a drink ♪
It's amazing!
♪ Everything but the shell ♪
♪ It's pure genius ♪
Genius Juice
is the first product
to include whole coconut
in every bottle.
Unlike regular coconut water,
we freshly crack open
organic young Thai coconut
and blend together the coconut
water and the coconut meat.
It's from tree to bottle
within five hours or less.
It's truly pure genius.
So, who wants to join us
on our genius journey?
♪ It's pure genius ♪
[ Lori and Barbara laugh ]
Oza: Nice job!
‐Yay! Bravo! Bravo!
‐Bravo! Marvelous!
Thank you.
Thank goodness
for their voices.
[ Laughter ]
Can I get you guys
some samples?
There you go.
This is the three flavors ‐‐
original ‐‐
Take one of each.
Okay.
One of each?
Perfect.
Yep, there you go.
Thank you.
Lori, you can take the ones
on your right.
Oh, thank you so much.
And also
there are straws here.
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
Barbara.
I think I can guess
what's next.
So, there's three flavors.
The green one
is the original,
and then turmeric,
and also coffee.
All of them have
whole coconut in it ‐‐
coconut water
and coconut meat.
This is
a full coconut in here?
Yeah, there's a full coconut
in every bottle.
How many calories
is this thing?
It's about 100 calories
per bottle.
Any added sugar?
No added sugars.
Anything added at all?
No, there's no added ‐‐
natural flavors.
No gums, no junk.
The original,
which is the green one,
that's coconut water,
coconut meat.
So delicious.
Thank you.
So creamy and delicious.
Yeah, once you get in
the mind‐set of a smoothie
and you're drinking
a smoothie,
then it's good.
It can be
a meal replacement.
And also the benefits of having
not only just coconut water,
which is potassium
and electrolytes,
but having
the coconut meat
is hitting on a lot
of great trends.
And it's only
100 calories?
100 calories, yeah.
I could eat this for lunch.
It's only 100 calories.
Me, too.
What do you sell each bottle
of coconut water for?
The retail price.
And what does it cost to make?
Yeah, so the coconut smoothie,
we sell at retail
between $4.99 and $5.99.
Mm‐hmm.
That's in the retail store.
Our cost to make it is $1.87.
And you have a co‐packer that's
doing this coconut blending?
Yeah, what's amazing is we have
a manufacturing partner
that is in Thailand
at the source
about two miles from
where the coconuts grow.
They source it at its peak
in nutrition and freshness,
they cut open the coconuts,
they extract the water
and the meat,
and they blend it
and bottle it.
And what preservative
do you have in it
so it makes it
across the ocean?
So, there's no preservative.
It's refrigerated
transportation?
It's actually frozen.
Oh, frozen.
So, we pasteurize it,
and when it's ready
to go to the stores,
we thaw it,
and it goes right to the stores.
That makes it
really tough,
'cause you got to get
refrigeration space.
Okay, well, with distribution,
we are with two of the largest
natural distributors
in the country.
Uh, we are currently
in about 1,100 stores.
Our distribution strategy
is, uh ‐‐
One of my mentors told me
"Inch wide, mile deep."
It's not about going into
a ton of stores.
Totally agree with you.
It's about going in the stores
where your product
will actually sell best
and pulling velocity.
What are you selling
in those 1,100 stores?
How much?
Last year,
we did $367,000...
Yeah.
...total.
This year, uh, so far,
halfway into the year,
we're at $320,000.
So, you're probably
gonna double it,
you think, potentially.
I think we're gonna triple it
because we're launching also
in 400 new locations
the end of next month,
and that's Vons and Pavilions
and Albertsons.
On the stores that
you've already sold to,
are they constantly
reordering?
Yeah. Yeah, we get reorders
every single week.
Assuming you're going to triple,
let's call it a millsky.
You're gonna do
a million bucks this year.
‐A millsky.
‐A millsky. [ Laughs ]
Okay, how much are you gonna
make on the millsky?
How much are you gonna lose
on the millsky?
So, we are not gonna be
net profitable
until about $2.5 million.
2.5 millskies.
Yeah, that's gonna be
our break‐even point.
How do I give this a valuation
of $3.5 million?
'Cause you're saying
$250,000 for 7%,
imputes a $3.5 million
valuation.
We are projecting to do
$6 million next year.
So, I'm gonna
make an assumption
you have a little flexibility
on valuation, right?
There is some flexibility.
I thought so.
Yeah, 'cause I would love
to partner up.
There should be
a lot of flexibility.
Corcoran: I would make
the assumption that you're gonna
need a lot more money
than $250,000.
Exactly.
Yeah, the $250,000
is going to be enough money
to get to a series A raise.
However, I'm definitely open
if there is a larger investment
where we can get there together.
I'm all ears.
Does anybody else do
a coconut smoothie?
No one else actually does this.
How much money have you put
into the business, Alex?
Yeah, about $1.3 million.
Wow!
That's a lot
of money, yeah.
‐You put?
‐You would need to ‐‐
Oh, not personally. No, no.
Oh, okay.
I myself put $150,000 in.
‐Okay.
‐And what do you own
in the business
at this point?
So, myself and a family member,
we own about 87%.
Ah.
Have you been delisted
with any retailers?
About three years ago,
we were at a co‐packer
here in Los Angeles,
and we were in about 450 stores
at that time.
And they were ‐‐
It was very abusive.
They were upcharging us,
they were moving us around.
We were forced to leave.
So we had no one
to make our product.
We lost all our shelf space
in the 450 stores.
So, I was able to arrange a deal
with our manufacturing partners.
Before, they were just
supplying us coconuts.
They not only invested in us,
they built machinery out
and made the product,
and by mid‐2017,
they were online,
they invested in us,
and I also managed to get almost
all of our shelf space back.
What percentage of your equity
do they own?
Right now, they're on
a convertible note,
so it's gonna equate
to about 3% to 4%.
Wow.
What's your
ultimate pain point,
and what's
your ultimate need?
Yeah, the pain point right now
is not having
enough marketing dollars.
You're gonna spend the whole
$250,000 on marketing?
We're gonna spend
about 65% on production...
‐Yeah.
‐...and about 30% on marketing
and 5% for working capital.
But you're gonna have to
do multiple rounds
as distribution grows
just for inventory, too, right?
Absolutely.
I love the packaging,
I love the look,
I love the logo ‐‐
everything.
I think it's really,
really great.
I do think, though,
the beverage industry
is very competitive,
and I just don't think
I have the expertise here
to help you.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Lori.
Oza: I think the product
is good, but food for thought ‐‐
the refrigeration
is definitely a concern.
Well, I look at ‐‐
This refrigerator
scares me.
Well, there's a lot of brands
that you have invested in
that are refrigerated.
They still scare me.
[ Laughter ]
And they ‐‐ they've actually ‐‐
they've really
taken off even more.
Yeah, I've ‐‐
It's been a lot of work,
you know, to push the brands
to get to scale.
So, now, I was involved
in Vita Coco.
Coconut water
can get scalable.
Vita Coco is, you know,
doing hundreds of millions of
dollars in sales at the moment.
The reason that it did so well
was...shelf stable.
My gut operationally
is telling me
this is gonna be a much longer
slog than you think,
and so, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Okay.
Boom laka laka laka,
boom laka laka laka.
Thank you, Rohan.
Alex,
does that discourage you,
hearing that
from a guy in the business?
Not at all.
There's plenty of
refrigerated beverages
that have grown and exited.
Alex, I invested in
two different soda companies
about three years apart.
I put my heart
and soul into it.
In the end,
they ran out of money,
the money went south,
and I swore to myself
I would never,
ever invest
in any kind of
a beverage company again.
All right?
But there's a few things here
that are tempting me.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
but Barbara may be interested
in Alex's coconut smoothie
company, Genius Juice.
I swore to myself
I would never, ever invest
in any kind of
a beverage company again.
All right?
But I love that this damn thing
is so delicious.
This coconut is the best
I've ever had.
Nothing else like it.
It's creamy, delicious.
I swear I'm drinking
1,000 calories,
but it's 100 calories.
That's great, all right?
And so for that reason,
I'm gonna go against my gut,
and I'm gonna
make you an offer.
But the 7% isn't gonna
get me up in the mornings.
I'll give you the $250,000,
but I want 14%.
Ouch!
Okay.
Corcoran:
That's not an "ouch."
‐That's an "ouch."
‐That's a "yahoo"!
A coconut fell
on your head.
And, Alex, I was interested,
but I would have asked for more.
And so I'll defer to Barb
since she's asking for less,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay, thank you, Mark.
I hate beverage deals 'cause of
the distribution problems
and all the other stuff
we're talking.
But this is good stuff.
Thank you.
Here's the problem
with the deal.
I know you're gonna have to
keep raising money
till the cows come home,
so if I give you $250,000
for 7% for $3.5 mill valuation,
I'm just gonna get diluted
into oblivion.
So, here's my offer.
I'll give you the $250,000.
It's debt, all right?
I'm gonna charge you 9% on it
for 3 years,
and I want the 7% equity.
You know, he's getting soft.
I love you, Alex.
Barbara, I can do $250,000
for 11%.
You're not interested in debt,
I take it?
No, I'm not interested
in debt.
Barb, if you put in $250,000
and I put in $250,000
and we get 25%,
'cause ‐‐
Oh, I would do that. That's more
of a bite‐size piece.
Yeah.
We're each gonna put,
Mark and I,
$250,000 in,
but we want 25%.
♪♪
I will take that deal.
‐Bingo.
‐Done.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Congratulations.
That is a smart man.
Well done.
Thanks.
And he's a hugger, too.
Who knew?
Big‐time hugger.
[ Laughs ] I'll take it.
Oza: Who would've thought?
‐The backup singers.
‐Thank you, Barbara.
I loved your response,
by the way.
Oh, thank you, yeah.
Positivity.
Terrific, terrific.
Alex, you got
two great Sharks in that.
Oh.
Greiner:
Really delicious.
Thank you, guys.
‐Congrats.
‐Congrats, Alex.
‐Okay.
‐Congrats.
‐Congratulations.
‐High‐five!
‐Oh! [ Laughs ]
‐Whoo!
Bayer:
I got two amazing Sharks
that have invested in a lot of
food and beverage companies.
They have a ton of experience,
and I think
they have what it takes
to join me
and also grow the company.
[ Laughter ]
Had to do that.
Mark, my two cents
on this thing?
Go deep.
Don't go nationwide.
We don't want your advice.
You didn't invest in it.
Oh, is that ‐‐ Okay.
All right.
That's okay.
I'll always take advice.
You know why I invested in it?
That's fine.
No ‐‐ No need.
Do you know why I invested?
Just to prove you wrong.
Barbara, I'm gonna
call you when I buy ‐‐
I hate when
you play big shot.
I'm gonna prove you wrong.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Next to me is my biggest
supporter and bubbe, Lois.
Narrator: In season 7,
16‐year‐old Ben Stern
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for his eco‐friendly
shampoo balls, Nohbo.
I knew that you'd be
impressed with him.
Yeah, and I was.
Narrator: Let's see how
Nohbo is doing now.
After "Shark Tank," I struggled
to bring Nohbo balls to market.
The customers
weren't that happy,
the product arrived broken,
it caked when
they tried to use them.
I ultimately had a bad product.
I worked with a team of chemists
for over two years
to reformulate.
It was a really bittersweet time
in my business.
While I was working
to reinvent the product,
I lost my grandmother, bubbe,
to cancer.
My grandmother was my supporter
from day one in this business,
and ever since my childhood,
she's been there for me.
It's driven me to
make this take off.
After hundreds of trials,
we were successfully able to
encapsulate shampoo
in a water‐soluble film.
We call them Nohbo Drops.
Nohbo Drops were an instant hit.
The second we launched,
we received inquiries
from around the globe,
and that's led to
our biggest news to date ‐‐
we've partnered with Bunzl,
a premier European
hotel distributor.
The value of this contract
is north of $14 million.
So, if I just cup my hands
under the water,
it starts turning
into shampoo right away?
Cuban:
The drops are amazing.
He's created a new product
that's unique.
Stern: We can make anywhere from
35 to 1,000‐plus gallons daily.
Cuban: Ben is global now,
and that's just the beginning.
We're gonna add
consumer subscriptions.
This literally could be
a $100 million enterprise
over the next five or six years.
I needed you to
get to the point
where the drops were ready
for prime time.
Now you get to come into
my wheelhouse.
Now we're gonna build out
the direct consumer,
now we're gonna build out
the subscription side.
And as painful
as it's been,
I promise you
it's gonna pay off.
Stern:
My "Shark Tank" experience
has absolutely changed my life.
It taught me how to
grow something from nothing.
I only wish my bubbe were here
for it.
Cuban:
Being an entrepreneur is hard,
but the test of
a true entrepreneur
is bouncing back when
things aren't going well.
Ben showed who he really is
as an entrepreneur.
He never quit.
And I'm so proud of him,
because this is just
the beginning for him.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a useful
tool in an ingenious package.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Chris Rodgers.
And I'm Geanie Rodgers
from Eagle, Idaho.
We're here
seeking $200,000
in exchange for a 20% stake
in our company, Rapid Rope.
Sharks, as parents of
five beautiful children
and an avid outdoorsman...
And outdoorswoman,
we can tell you,
you have to be ready
for the unexpected,
no matter where you are.
That's right.
You can never be too prepared.
[ Groans ]
[ Laughs ]
Geanie, get the rope!
[ Growls ]
It's all tangled!
The Rapid Rope!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Laughter continues ]
Rohan, I didn't know
you had a twin.
My cousin.
And that's how you survive
a zombie attack.
[ Laughter ]
But seriously, Rapid Rope
is a uniquely designed
rope‐dispensing system with
unlimited applications,
like camping...
Gardening...
Hunting...
Around the house...
Fishing...
And, of course,
zombie attacks.
Plus it has a cut‐ready
insert on top.
To cut the rope,
not your fingers.
It's that simple.
Each canister houses 120 feet
of extreme utility rope
that's rated at
1,100 pounds.
That's a lot of zombies.
And if you run out of rope,
no problem ‐‐
you have a cartridge inside,
you replace it.
Cuban: Oh, that's cool.
[ Canister clicks ]
Just like that.
Any experienced
outdoorsman ‐‐
Or outdoorswoman.
...or outdoorswoman
always has rope on hand
when they need it most.
Sharks, you do not
want to miss out.
We're not here
to string you along.
Ah.
Who's ready to tie up a deal
with Rapid Rope?
Ha.
Let's get you
some samples.
‐Yeah, please.
‐Please.
[ Groans ]
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Oh, no.
He's, like,
really scary, actually.
[ Growls ]
I love the leg drag.
No out of character for you.
Thank you, David ‐‐
or formerly known as David.
‐Thank you.
Go away.
[ Laughs ]
Lori.
‐Here you go.
‐I don't like that.
‐[ Growls ]
‐Okay. Thank you.
[ Roars ]
[ Laughter ]
Easy, big boy.
That's right.
How much to take out Kevin?
Just a little bite.
Greiner: Oh, my God.
Here you go, Mark.
[ Laughs ]
[ Growls ]
Mm.
Oza: I love the pitch.
That zombie was
one of the coolest
intros that I've seen.
Yeah, it was great.
It was great.
Oza: Tell us your story.
Okay.
Um, I am a nurse.
Met Chris
going to nursing school.
Chris:
I keep the lights on.
So, I've been an electrical
lineman for over 20 years.
Everything I do in my job,
we use rope,
and I've also been an avid
outdoorsman and a hunting guide,
and everything we do
is with rope,
and it's always
just a traditional,
kind of a knotted mess.
Can I ask you, why did you
decide on this particular rope?
For one,
the strength.
How strong is it?
Could it hold Mark?
He's a little heavy.
Yeah, so ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
We actually have a video
to show.
Yeah, we do have a video
to show the strength
of the rope.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
So, this is
a 2,000‐pound shed.
Wow.
We did double the rope,
but we're lifting it
with this crane here.
And this just
is a good example
to show of how strong
this rope actually is.
Wow!
Okay, so, $200,000 investment
for 20% of the company?
Yes, sir.
You must have
a few sales going on.
Yeah, so, we launched
just about two years ago.
We have right at $172,000
in lifetime sales.
That's not bad.
So, what is
your means of selling?
Are you online only?
Are you at retail?
So, right now,
we're about 60% retail
and about 40% online
right now.
O'Leary: Which retailers?
Um, well, a large company
that we just signed with
is Duluth Trading.
Oh, good for you.
And, yeah, we're just
gonna be fulfilling
our second PO
with them soon.
Okay, break down
the numbers for me.
Retails for $24.95,
wholesales right at $14.97.
What's it cost you
to make?
Uh, with labor,
it's right at $5.65.
And where do you
make them at?
So, we have everything
in‐house.
So, that's one of the great
things about...
All American‐made?
Making jobs in Idaho.
In‐house?
In Duluth?
Chris:
All American‐made.
And we build them all,
put them together,
our family,
our kids, in our shop.
‐You do them? Really?
‐Yeah.
Greiner: So, you know,
in thinking about this,
I'm not very outdoorsy handy.
I don't know how I could
blow up rope for you.
I'm out.
Okay. Well, thank you.
Thank you.
Guys, could I ‐‐
We are all‐in.
We did put in our own money ‐‐
$115,000.
‐Wow.
‐And we are debt‐free.
Are you both full‐time
in this now?
S‐‐
So, that's
a good question.
So, we would want
those lifetime sales to be more.
We started in 2017.
2017 late and 2018
was a little hard for us.
We have a son that we adopted
from Ethiopia,
and he was, um ‐‐
he was diagnosed with
ulcerative colitis.
He had a lot of
health issues.
So, through that time,
we spent a lot of trips
back and forth
to Seattle Children's
from our home.
Every dime, every moment,
every time that we had,
it was making sure
that he was getting
the proper care
that he needed.
My wife,
she quit her job
so we would have
adequate time for that,
and I needed to have
that security
of the job that I had
with the insurance
and everything like that
before we could
jump in with both feet
with Rapid Rope.
How's he doing?
He's doing amazing.
‐Good.
‐Great.
He's gaining weight.
How old is your son?
12.
He's 12.
And what inspired you
to do that?
You already had four kids.
You know, I think it was just
deep down part of who we are.
We always knew we wanted
to give back, and...
you know,
Zade inspired us
and helped us probably more
than we helped him, for sure.
You know,
that is our "why."
It's not the money.
Our purpose is to be able
to give back.
We feel a responsibility ‐‐
‐Good for you guys.
‐That's lovely.
...our whole family does ‐‐
to build a school
in Zade's name,
and we volunteer for
an organization
that helps children
in Africa.
We did a fun run for them
last Saturday.
That's who we are.
You guys make me feel like
a really bad parent.
[ Laughs ]
[ Chuckles ]
Look, I mean,
I'm not an outdoors guy.
It's just not my speed,
but congratulations.
Thank you.
I mean, it's in your heart,
it's in your face,
it's in your smile.
Thank you.
You guys glow when you talk
about your family
and the business...
Yeah, absolutely.
...so I see nothing but
great things for you,
but unfortunately, I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Congrats.
I also think
you're terrific people.
The challenge is, I don't know
how to blow it up.
I'm out.
Guys, we have a lot of great
entrepreneurs come on this show.
You guys are special people.
Thank you.
This is the American dream,
and you're domestic‐made,
your products are local,
you put your all into it.
I don't know exactly
how to help.
I mean, I want to help you
as people,
but from a business standpoint,
something doesn't fit.
My only help that I could
probably give is,
you guys just did a run to raise
money for your African cause...
Yeah.
...so I would like
to add to that run.
Awesome.
I'll donate
$10,000 to that.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
But as far as
an investment standpoint,
it's tough for me to
get behind this
'cause I'm not sure I could
provide the value you guys need.
For that reason, I'm out.
You know, I've been sitting here
thinking to myself,
"What do I know about rope?"
Not a damn thing.
[ Laughter ]
But I've fallen in love
with you,
which is not a good reason to
make a business decision at all,
except, ironically,
my best decisions on this show
have been from my heart,
and those, ironically,
are the ones I've made
the most money from.
You're standing here, and you
remind me of Grace & Lace.
What is rockin' amazing
about Grace & Lace
and why they deserve the
enormous success they have,
$86,000 to $46 million
in sales...
Wow.
...remarkable story,
is because they've built,
I believe,
12 orphanages
and 2 schools in India.
Wow.
They take their money
and they share.
Yeah.
They're just good people
from the top of their head
to their heel.
You're the walking,
talking example
of the American dream, period.
Thank you.
And I have no doubt in my mind
you're gonna make it.
Okay, so, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'm going to give you the
$200,000 which you asked for,
but I want 30%
with the contingency
that we agree on
how the money is spent.
Take it.
Would you go 25%?
I don't love you that much.
No, 30%.
Ha!
[ Laughter ]
Remember,
it's still a Shark Tank.
We appreciate everybody here
today and taking your time,
but, Barbara,
we'll accept your offer.
‐Yeah!
‐Whoo!
[ Applause ]
Congratulations,
guys.
‐Congrats, guys.
Thank you so much.
Geanie:
When Barbara said she made
the decision from the heart,
it just made me feel like
what drives us
to do what we do
has a purpose.
If we can raise our children
to give back
and to make a difference
in humanity and in this world,
that is our
number‐one goal.
‐[ Growls ]
‐Oh, he's back?
‐No, no!
‐Aah!
‐He's back!
‐[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God,
get out of here!
Get him, get him!
[ Growls ]
[ Roars ]
Ohh!
Corcoran: Oh, my God! Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a solution
to a growing concern
for children.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Daniel Zekowski.
I'm Dr. Katie Marks‐Cogan.
And I'm
Dr. Andy Lightner.
We're from Los Angeles,
and we're seeking $350,000
for 7% equity in our company.
Ready.
Set.
Together: Food!
Sharks, did you know
that babies aren't born
with food allergies?
They develop over time.
But now clinical studies suggest
that feeding allergenic foods ‐‐
like peanuts, eggs, and milk ‐‐
to babies
can actually help prevent
food allergies.
As an allergist,
this is really exciting news.
That's amazing, right?
But feeding peanuts and eggs
to babies
can be difficult
'cause they have no teeth.
[ Ding! ]
That's why we've outsmarted
these babies
by creating
Ready, Set, Food!
Our revolutionary approach makes
this super simple for parents
by turning organic peanut,
egg, and milk
into powder
that dissolves easily
in breast milk or formula.
Just tear open
a packet...
pour it
into the bottle...
...give it
a quick shake,
and it's ready for
your baby to drink.
It's as easy as
one bottle a day.
And babies love
Ready, Set, Food!
Okay, they can't actually
taste it,
but they'd be thrilled
to know
they're on the path
to an allergy‐free future,
which is why it's so important
for every parent
to be doing
early allergen introduction.
Sharks,
who's ready to join us
to help the millions of babies
born every year
reduce their risk
of food allergies?
We're ready.
Ready.
Set.
Together: Food!
Marks‐Cogan: If anyone wants to
go ahead and take a sip...
Oza: Okay.
...we can start with that.
It tastes like
a light peanut.
It has a light
peanut flavor,
but they typically
can't taste that
over the breast milk
or the formula.
You're saying
if you feed a baby
a tiny, tiny, tiny dose
of the allergen,
they build up an immunity
to getting allergic to it?
What we know from
landmark clinical trials
and now national guidelines
is that feeding babies
allergenic foods during infancy,
when their immune systems
are still developing,
we have a chance to help
mold their immune systems
towards tolerance.
So, you're giving eggs,
you're giving peanuts,
you're giving, you know,
typical well‐known allergens.
But this doesn't cover all
allergic food groups, right?
So, that's a great point.
We chose these three allergens
for two reasons ‐‐
prevalence
and quality of life.
Peanut, egg, and milk
are the most common
childhood food allergens.
Okay.
They also make up 80% of
food allergies in children,
and you know that milk and egg
are everywhere ‐‐
pizza, cake, cupcakes,
cookies, et cetera.
And so think about
the quality of life
for that food‐allergic child
and their family.
Are there any children that
should not use this protocol?
Right, like...
Any child who's diagnosed
with a food allergy
should speak with
their pediatrician first
just, you know,
like they shouldn't eat
any foods
they're allergic to.
You're recommending go to your
doctor first, your pediatrician.
But is there any signal that
would say "Never use this"?
Absolutely.
Just a pre‐existing allergy
would be the only signal.
How long is the protocol?
Ready, Set, Food! recommends
continuing it for six months...
Six months.
...or until
the baby is regularly
eating those foods
in their diet.
I want to find out
about sales.
Oza: Right.
Well,
we have great sales.
‐Good.
‐Year to date,
we've had
$250,000 of sales,
and that was
a very soft launch
focused mostly on
pediatricians' offices.
This is
your first full year.
Correct.
And then what do you expect
to end the year at?
We expect to end the year
a little above, like, $450,000.
$400,000 ‐‐ okay.
And where are you selling?
So, we sell right now through
our website and Amazon,
and we also have
about 300 pediatricians
that recommend our product
in their office.
And how long
are your subscriptions?
On average, 4 1/2 months is
how long people stay with us
for an average amount of
probably about $150,
but we're gonna be launching
other products later this year
that will allow us to
extend lifetime value
so that we'll have products
to protect babies
from food allergies from birth
until 4 years of age.
Is there anything proprietary
about this formula
that I can't
knock off myself?
There is. Our patent pending
has many features,
but the three most important
are the bottle introduction
so that all babies can do this
at the right time.
The second
is this guided system
so it's easy
for families to use.
Do you have competition?
We do have
some competition.
We're the only product
who introduces allergens
through a bottle.
Our competitors have
a variety of products ‐‐
for example,
applesauce pouches
that already
have allergens in it.
But those are just not
the right format.
How did you
come up with this?
So, let me tell you
a little bit
about the inspiration
for the company.
We actually have
a photo of him,
and I'll tell you
about my family.
‐Aww.
‐So, that's Abe.
‐Cute.
‐So, Abe is 3 years old.
I'm a practicing
physician.
I work
at a cancer hospital.
There was a time
in the past
where I had to
rush home from work
because Abe was having a severe
food‐allergy reaction.
Oh, my gosh.
I wouldn't want anyone
to go through
that experience.
Oh, we have.
So, that's why I'm so passionate
about our mission
to prevent food allergies
before they start.
How much cash have you invested
in the business?
So far, we've raised
$2.4 million...
‐Ooh.
‐Wow!
...all at the same valuation
that we're inviting you
to join at.
When I look at this, I think
it doesn't promise enough.
I'd like it to clearly say
"Avoids allergies,"
but you can't make that claim.
You can't go that far
to actually say
"Avoids allergies," right?
That's exactly right.
So, that's why we primarily
focus through online sales
where we can wrap it
in additional context
and education that really helps
describe the product.
Yeah, but you still
have to be there to
describe it, to say it.
You've got to put other words.
Right, 'cause you have
your name ‐‐ Yeah.
So, it's not
clear as a crystal bell
that if I pick this up,
I'm gonna avoid allergies.
I think that's a weakness,
and for those reasons, I'm out.
What does it cost me
to buy this?
$48 a month
is our retail price.
And what does it cost you
to make it?
Our cost right now is $10.50,
so we have 70% margin.
What's my total cost
per child?
So, if you pre‐pay all up front,
it's $200.
If you pay month by month,
it's $288.
So, for $288, I can maybe stop
my child from having an allergy?
Yes, absolutely.
That's a good
value proposition.
Does it have to be equity?
I feel
a royalty's coming.
I would do this deal
one of two ways.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out,
but Kevin is interested in
Ready, Set, Food!,
a food‐allergy prevention
protocol for children.
I would do this deal
one of two ways.
I'll do the $350,000...
for 11%.
The other way is
I give it to you as debt.
I loan it to you,
I'll do it at 8%,
three years,
and I'll take 5% equity.
Those are the two ways
you could look at it.
But there's an offer,
and, you know,
let's hear if
there's any others
that are more attractive
than that.
I'm having trouble
because on the one hand,
like,
I absolutely love this.
But I would only want
to do it as a loan
and get some type
of royalty.
What would that look like
for you?
I would give you the $350,000
as a loan at 2%,
but I would want $1 per
up to half a million,
and then I would go with
the 7% equity.
My problem is awareness.
You're so new, you're going to
need a lot of money,
and there's some things that
I'm willing to back the bus up.
But it scares me to do that
on too many deals.
And unfortunately,
for that reason, I'm out.
I don't think
the marketing
is about spending money
on marketing.
I think the education
is inherent
because every parent
freaks out about it,
so they go
and they educate themselves.
So they will self‐educate,
then they'll start looking
where to find a solution.
I'm gonna make you
an offer,
and there's gonna be
a contingency, okay?
I'll give you the $350,000,
I want 12%,
2% of that can be in advisory,
but the contingency is that
we do a low‐cost version,
and that for every subscription
that we sell,
we do one free
to a low‐income parent.
Right?
That's my offer.
So, in summary,
it's $350,000 for 12%.
$350,000, of which 2%
can be advisory shares.
So, you knew you were gonna
have to negotiate some
anyways, right?
And you can negotiate
back to me, too.
And you knew you were gonna
have to play that game anyway.
But wait, guys.
Wait, guys.
So, let's discuss,
right?
'Cause if you don't think
this is your offer,
then just tell me.
We would love to
have you as a partner,
but I think for us, like,
an equity deal
just makes more sense.
Would you be looking at
an equity deal,
or is that off the table
'cause you ‐‐
Oh, damn, okay. Well, if you
guys don't want me, then ‐‐
No, no, no.
No. So, Mark, also,
I think getting back
to your offer,
is there any way you could do
for 9.5%, $350,000?
Basically meet halfway
in between the 7% and 12%.
That ‐‐
I'm still listening.
Um, you know, listen,
keep talking to me,
and Mark will
keep going down.
[ Laughs ]
Keep talking to me. You're gonna
get a better deal from Mark.
No, I'll do it at the 10%,
'cause 9.5% is just ridiculous.
So 10%.
‐Let's do a deal.
‐Great. Done.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Wow.
I'm excited about this.
I wish I would've had it
when my kids were young.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congratulations.
‐Katie, thank you so much.
We're gonna save
a lot of kids together.
Oh, absolutely.
This is really, really exciting.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, guys.
You're gonna put a lot more
money in. You know that?
Marks‐Cogan: We're so pumped,
and we're just so motivated
to have Mark on board.
Zekowski: We're just gonna
take that excitement
and use it to bring
Ready, Set, Food!
to every baby in America
so that they all can have
the best chance at not
developing food allergies.
We're ready.
Ready.
Set.
Together: Food!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a modern snack
made from an ancient grain.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Dustin Finkel,
and I'm the CEO and founder
of Ancient inGRAINed ‐‐
Oh, no,
not these guys again.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Stand back, Sharks.
I'll handle this.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, my Lord.
Okay, player.
[ Laughs ]
Gluten, not this time!
Yeah!
Allergens,
get out of here.
Mm,
didn't go that far.
Empty calories?
Ha!
Nice try.
GMOs? Never!
Whew.
‐Whew!
‐Wow. Oh.
‐That's fantastic.
I'm sorry about that, Sharks.
I have made it my life's mission
to defeat bad guys like that,
and I've done what I can,
but I need your help.
I'm here today
asking for $350,000,
and in exchange,
I'm willing to offer 5%...
Ooh.
...of the strongest weapon
we have ‐‐
Ka‐Pop! Ancient Grain pop chips
powered by sorghum!
Sorghum is an ancient grain
unadulterated since the times
of ancient Egypt.
It remains in its original form,
having never been altered
in any way.
It is loaded with
whole‐grain fiber,
protein, antioxidants,
and minerals ‐‐
all you need to make
our delicious flavors,
like our number‐one‐selling
rosemary garlic,
our salt and vinegar...
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐...vegan cheddar...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐...and olive oil and sea salt.
We are vegan, non‐GMO,
gluten‐free, and allergen‐free,
but we're not taste‐free.
Sharks, now with
our powers combined,
we can make Ka‐Pop!
a true snacking superhero!
I will now pass out samples.
‐Good job.
‐Very good.
‐Wow.
‐Thank you.
‐Okay.
‐Here we go.
So, if you want to take
one of those.
One of these?
We have four flavors ‐‐
vegan cheddar...
These two.
I'll take these two.
...salt and vinegar.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
‐I'll go cheddar and garlic.
‐Fantastic.
Mr. Wonderful, how are you?
Thank you, thank you.
Barbara, how are you?
Corcoran:
I'm good, Dustin.
[ Laughter ]
Hello, Mark. How are you?
Hello. I'm good,
'cause I'm a growing boy.
Mmm.
Take all of them.
I got cases after cases
for you.
No doubt.
All we are is literally sorghum
with no fillers.
We air‐pop it, add cold‐pressed
oil and seasoning ‐‐
nothing else.
So, I can tell you a little bit
about my background.
I've spent 13 years
in the food industry.
Before that, I was an investment
banker at Goldman Sachs.
I went to General Mills,
where I launched
the first nationwide
gluten‐free product ever.
I've worked on numerous brands,
but this is my first start‐up.
And I did this because I wanted
authentically healthy snacks
that deliver
authentic nutrition,
and that's what
you're eating here today.
O'Leary:
I want to tell you something.
I've tried a lot of this GMO,
no carb, blah‐da,
yada, yada, yada.
This is good.
‐Very good.
‐Thank you very, very much.
‐It is good.
‐Really good.
‐Tasty.
‐Great product.
Thank you so much,
Rohan.
It's gonna be fun 'cause
it's one of the first times
in "Shark Tank" history
where we have an actual
investment banker
at a crazy valuation.
[ Laughter ]
Oza: This is
going to be great.
‐Let's have some fun.
‐How do you know it's crazy?
This is a great valuation.
You're in my wheelhouse,
buddy.
Explain why you're worth
$7 million.
So, our sales were $150,000
as we just got going last year.
This year, we're on pace
to do about $1.2 million.
Wow.
In the last ‐‐
Any profits?
I'll come back to profits
in a second.
I don't like that answer.
Well, $50,000
three months ago,
$60,000, $70,000,
we're on pace to do
$70,000‐plus this month.
The reality in the food space,
unfortunately,
is it's really
a gross‐margin game.
So, we are doing outstanding
on a gross‐margin front.
We're high 40s, low 50s
on our gross margin.
Is that after trade spend?
That's after trade spend.
Yeah.
I have game‐changer
type of investors.
So, I have the ex‐head
of Whole Foods grocery,
I have the founder
of Boulder Brands,
the founder of
Pacific Foods.
They're investors
in my company.
‐Invested.
‐Oh, investors? Wow.
One of the reasons that I've
been so successful so far ‐‐
we're 1,000 doors,
100% selling rate ‐‐
is they open the door.
You put me in front of someone,
I will sell them.
How much have
you put in personally,
and how much have you taken
in investment?
So, I initially put in
$50,000 to start.
What about investors?
So, investors,
my first pre‐revenue round
took on $943,000,
including my money.
‐Wow.
That's a lot to take in.
That's your first
pre‐revenue round.
It was not expected.
I was going out there,
selling hard, hustling.
It was the hardest thing I've
ever done was pre‐revenue raise.
Got that. No, okay,
so let's put that aside,
'cause you're a grinder,
we know it...
Yep. Yep.
...you're smart,
you've been there.
Right.
How much more
have you taken in,
and how much of the company
do you own right now?
So, I just started
another round.
Most of my first‐round people
want to come back in,
which is a great sign.
That's good.
We have some
Forbes 400 people
that are also interested in
coming in on this round.
Good for you.
At this point,
I still have 100%
'cause they're all
convertible notes.
Yeah, but you know
what I'm saying.
And so after
the first round, 67%.
How much are you trying
to raise in total?
I am trying to raise
about $1 million.
Okay.
What you're really here for
is strictly cash?
‐No, not at all.
‐Nah.
What else?
Not at all.
I have plenty of cash,
actually,
and I have plenty of interest
from this round.
I'd like to know
what's at stake here for you
if you don't get a deal.
I believe what ‐‐
being here,
partnering with you guys,
adds fuel to the fire
in no other way I can get
from anybody else.
This is an incredible
opportunity.
Sincerely, since the day
the show came on air,
if you ask my wife,
my family,
this has been
literally my dream.
I was standing back,
getting ready for this,
and mind‐blown
that this was happening.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Good for you.
‐That's amazing.
‐This has literally
been my dream.
I never had my own idea,
and then I had a great idea,
and I came here.
Oza: What's to stop Popchips ‐‐
great brand name,
well‐known ‐‐
saying, "Hey, we're gonna launch
an ancient grain line"?
This is about perseverance
and execution
in the branding
and food space.
Every single brand
I've ever worked on,
I've had success on.
I haven't had
one failure to date.
I'm gonna do
the same thing here.
Dustin,
I believe your real gift
is you're one hell
of a salesman.
Thank you.
And you look the part.
You look like you're
an ancient grain man, you know?
Okay.
[ Laughs ]
So I like
the whole imaging, okay?
Thank you.
But there's not a thing I feel
I could do for this business.
And I like to feel like
I make a difference
in anything I step into.
So, my congratulations,
but I'm out.
I'm very, very sorry
to hear that.
You were one of the Sharks
who I think
could actually add a lot of
value to my business.
Dustin, let me jump in.
Look.
Yeah.
You are a good salesperson,
but you oversell.
You didn't talk about what your
challenges were going to be.
It was like you were trying to
pitch us why we need you.
Right? Just sometimes,
you got to stop selling and say,
"Look, here's where
you can help me,"
because that's where
true confidence comes through.
Seems like a great product,
but for those reasons, I'm out.
Appreciate the feedback.
It's good feedback. Thank you.
You're welcome.
I would hire you,
by the way.
I kind of disagree
a little bit
with my fellow Sharks
on the other end.
Uh...
I'll take you up on that
one day.
If this thing doesn't pan out,
just come to me.
I'm telling you,
I would put you in
to run any one
of my companies.
So, you know, obviously,
I'm in the snack business.
It's not an easy business.
So, my problem is,
you're very early.
Margins are good,
but this industry
has crushing trade spend
that will just
jam your margins down.
And as you scale up,
you're gonna have to manpower
up, et cetera, et cetera.
And while I like you
and I'll take you anywhere,
I'm concerned
the journey is too arduous.
So, unfortunately, I'm out.
That's very sad
to hear.
Greiner: I like the product.
I am your market.
The thing is,
I kind of like jumping in
where I know that I can
really help people,
and I think you've got a lot
of people with you
that can do that.
So, I'm sorry, I'm out.
That's crushing.
You've heard all the other
Sharks talk about the risks.
I get all that.
I don't have ancient grains
in my portfolio right now.
[ Laughter ]
So, it's interesting.
But there's risk
and there's reward, all right?
Of course.
5%, I don't even
get out of bed for,
because I know with certainty
I have to participate
in every round after that
to keep this tiny position,
regardless of
what the valuation is.
The only way I would do this
is turn back time.
I'd give you the $350,000,
I want 17.5%.
That's a $2 million
valuation.
'Cause otherwise, I'm just gonna
get diluted into oblivion
because you're gonna have to
raise so much money.
The bottom‐line value
that we've talked about
as a company for this round
has been $5 million
from a cap perspective.
I don't want to screw you up
on that,
but when you say
you have a Shark
and it's Mr. Wonderful,
there's Sharks,
and then there's...
[Vocalizes]
Mr. Wonderful.
What about $500,000
for 10%?
No. No.
You know, you're stuck
at that $5 million. I get it.
I understand your problem.
Our universes are not aligned.
I'm a superhero, too,
and we're flying around
different planets.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm a superhero."
Mr. Wonderful!
Tell you what,
I'll arm‐wrestle you
for my valuation,
and we'll see who wins.
I think you'd win.
Greiner:
Oh, go for it! Do it!
It's gonna be heartbreaking
to walk out of here
without something.
Dustin, we are miles apart,
and there's no middle ground.
That's the problem.
The lowest I think I can go
from a valuation,
to be fair and equitable
to everyone, is $4 million.
I don't think I can go
lower than that.
It's 100% more than
what I'm willing to pay.
Yep.
Sometimes the valuation gap
is too large.
I'm a Shark.
You are.
I do Shark deals.
So do I ‐‐
except now, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
‐Dustin.
‐And you will.
You know what?
You will.
‐Dustin, thank you very much.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
Cuban: Good luck.
Congratulations, Dustin.
Appreciate it. Thanks, guys.
‐Good luck, Dustin.
‐Take care.
‐Great job.
He'll be fine.
He's rock‐solid.
Finkel: We didn't get a deal,
but the Sharks
loved the product,
and that's a home run
in my book.
We're gonna keep going,
and we're gonna show everyone
what Ka‐Pop! can be,
and we're gonna be everywhere
you want a great, healthy,
salty snack.
♪♪